[Music]
you think you know how the world works
you think that this material universe is
all there is but what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many this
doesn't make any sense not everything
has to dr. strange
through the mystic arts we harness
energy and shape reality
you're Avengers protect the world from
physical changes we safeguarded against
more mystical threats
come with me
who died protecting this world mr.
doctor
mr. doctor it's strange maybe Who am I
to judge
what if I told you the reality you know
is one of many dr. strange represents an
entirely new aspect to the cinematic
universe just like in the comics dr.
strange deals with parallel dimensions
deals with the multiverse the comics are
very very out there and we've pushed it
with how we film this for movies like
this IMAX is more immersive every set
piece is an attempt to give audiences
visuals and sequences in ways that we
haven't seen them done before open your
eye
Steve Ditko is one of the greatest
Marvel artists in history and that we're
now able to take what he put in the
mid-60s
these trippy comic panels and comic
covers and we now have the technology to
put that into big three-dimensional
space on a movie screen is amazing and
we're not pulling back have a good trip
mr. strange girls like the Avengers
protect the world from physical dangers
we safeguarded against more mystical
fencer come with me
why are you showing this to me
because I believe you can save the world
I'm defending from those who would make
it happen
are you ready mr. strange it's doctor
actually Buddha pg-13 get tickets now
dr. strange you think you know how the
world works
what if I told you the reality you know
is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to
[Music]
for the mystic arts we harness energy
and shape reality
travel great distances in an instant
so I get from here to there how did you
become a doctor studying practice
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
the devil which paths you travel
downstream stronger men than you have
left away
I have death
and pain
you'll die protect all this world
I can't do this there is no other way
I've spent so many years
airing full-time
looking for you
what's this my launcher it's the Wi-Fi
password we're not savages dr. strange
your work saved the lives of thousands
what if I told you that reality is one
of many strange is incredibly arrogant
brilliant sort of extraordinary and his
need to control fates to control destiny
and in particular death has bought into
the hype is professionals in your
resurgent he has car crush and he loses
the use of his hands and she spends all
his money having operations to have his
hands put back together and they don't
work he has quite a journey as his life
starts to fall apart deep spend his last
pennies on a ticket goes to the pool
he's searching for a cure for his hands
and the issues that he's having my
character introduces him to this
different very mystical world he finds
the ancient one who is the sorcerer
supreme you wonder what I see in your
future possibility
brings out this spiritual dimension
which he never knew was possible he soon
realizes the potential is someone who
could help on a grander scale that he'd
ever imagined actually existed
we're excited about the villains in this
film these are people who become seduced
by what they find on the other side new
diet I suppose well they are contrasted
in spilling the barriers between these
dimensions which would annihilate our
entire universe I can't do this who is
not other way there's a lot of real
world live action in this film there's a
lot of drama a lot of comedy there's
also the most extraordinary fantastical
adventure I think is gonna be a great
cinematic Rider
[Music]
stories a great cast of characters chief
among them is Carl immortal well it
certainly is the intro to dr. strange
entering this universe Mauro is very
close with the ancient one played by
Tilda Swinton she deals in magic in real
proper inner magic together both the
ancient one and Mauro they sort of begin
his training there are other ways to
save lives so much you don't know
we're excited about villains in this
film you call them the zealots these are
people who become seduced by what they
find on the other side Casillas is part
of this temple if the majority is
looking for the truth here he's looking
over there for the truth he is
interested in spilling the barriers
between these dimensions
[Music]
anywho precise to say it's time time oh
I must smiley time
time yeah
this is just the beginning hitter now as
all of you are well aware Marvel Studios
can do some pretty amazing things on
screen
and since joining the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as dr. Stephen strange I can
tell you that Marvel family is just as
incredible behind the scenes
we're completely inspired and humbled by
the half the strength and the passion of
you our fans each and every one of them
so I'm very excited to announce today a
new charitable initiative that enables
us to do even more together Marvel
Studios hero apps is a global initiative
focused on bringing help and hope to
kids around the world when they need it
most we film Doctor Strange in the pool
and several other countries and
everywhere we went in the world I met
Marvel fans but I also saw kids who are
facing enormous challenges challenges
that no one should ever have to face
with the help of our fans hero acts can
change that how what is easy and I know
from my recent trip to Comicon they're
like you're really good at this so here
it is to help us launch hero acts post a
photo of yourself in your favorite
Marvel hero pose just go to Marvel
Studios hero acts calm upload your photo
and share across your social media
channels with the below hashtags for
every post from now until the end of the
year Marvel Studios will donate five
dollars to the charity Save the Children
this will help them to provide
much-needed learning materials to as
many as 123 thousand kids in the fall
peytie
in the United States
you can learn more at marvel studios he
relaxed calm I can't wait to see your
hero poses just to get us started let me
show you mine
[Music]
you
you
Stephen strange might I offer you some
advice
forget everything that you think your
long
your man looking at the world through a
keyhole
you've spent your life trying to widen
it
your work saved the night clouds
what if I told you that reality is one
of many
I don't believe in fairytales about
chakras or energy or the power of belief
you wonder what I see in your future
possibility
why are you doing this
so much you don't know
he's Brittany's knees better
I'm ready Hewlett such does it open your
eye
you can become so much home
yeah
[Music]
this is just the beginning hi imax fans
I'm Benedict Cumberbatch October the
10th I invite you to check out a special
sneak peak of Doctor Strange exclusively
and select IMAX theaters there being a
sorcerer supreme I don't really need to
invite you I can technically just bend
the fabric of time and space to enter a
parallel reality and make you do it but
I imagine you'll probably just want to
do it on your own so go to IMAX comm for
more information
you
I needed to me time and I came to
Australia and that's when I moved in
with Daryl hello
and here we are you know it's a nice
flat